always remember the universe has a way
of leading into where you're supposed to
be
the moment you're supposed to be there
let's do this
took me 20 years to find you I lived if
I can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you which makes me
perfect for this job
you really think a black suit it's going
to solve all your problems
no but looks damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as DejaVu and
dismissed just as quickly time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London welcome to my brief you will
be with agent peach one of the best ever
to wear this suit catching up on my
daily meditation time for lunch ah thank
you hungry it's 9:30 it's Tuesday's taco
day
[Music]
of this planet at risk
[Applause]
if you could all just look right here
just try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like the tables of time everybody
it's Charlie we got brand new Thor for
footage to break down if you were
confused about what's going on here
Tessa Thompson and Chris Hemsworth are
continuing in the men and black
franchise the trailer has a couple shots
that let you know that it's a
continuation of the Will Smith franchise
like this is forward in time within that
universe so they're not trying to reboot
the Will Smith movies this is just the
next movie after that it's like men in
black 4 with different characters in a
different part of the world there are a
whole bunch of Easter eggs a lot of Thor
jokes obviously they're gonna do Thor
jokes because they just did Thor
Ragnarok together why wouldn't they lean
on that just because that movie was so
successful and that's what he's known
for if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos this
is coming out June 14th next year so
in-between Avengers endgame in
spider-man far from home so even though
it's not a Marvel film it will probably
feel like a Marvel film just because
there's so much Marvel stuff happening
in that part of the year the basic
premise of the movie is that the men in
black is a world wide organization they
have branches in every major city so
this is following a couple different
agents Tessa Thompson is the new one
that learns about the organization she's
just smart enough she decodes the clues
and confronts them about it Emma
Thompson inducks her at the same place
where all the Will Smith movies took
place in New York City she goes to the
entrance where Will Smith used to go
Emma Thompson is the new head of that
branch I don't know what her agent
designation is but they have a couple of
jokes about giving her the tiny small
gun that Will Smith got thinking that it
wasn't very powerful but it gave off
this giant energy blast knocking him
back there's even a couple paintings on
the wall depicting the events of the
Will Smith movie that's just to let you
know that they're not rebooting anything
like all this stuff still happened it
was just a long time ago in the past
they make a couple of jokes about the
tropes of the men and black franchise
like the actual black suits that they
wear while they're suiting her up
there's a lot of Liam Neeson voice over
dialogue he's the one that gives us the
plot about a mole being inside the
agency and that's sort of like the
overarching plot is there's a mole in
men and black threatening the safety of
the planet he tells us Chris Hemsworth
is one of the most legendary agents out
of the London branch and he has a couple
of very Thor moments when you first meet
him like he has a couple really bad
take downs but then in a very Valkyrie
Thor type moment she catches him
sleeping on the job and acting a little
bit like Thor like Oh 9:30 all right
it's Taco Tuesday let's go get some
lunch
at 9:30 in the morning bright and early
so early on I'm kind of wondering if
it's actually Liam Neeson that winds up
being the mole because he's the one that
sort of driving this plot and they want
you to think like this is this amazing
branch where nothing has gone wrong you
have this legendary agent H Chris
Hemsworth's character that seems like
maybe he doesn't quite see everything so
maybe he wouldn't see the clues that
Liam Neeson's character was the mole but
the way agent n Tessa Thompson's
character balances him out is that she
does seem like a bit of a detective
because at the beginning of the trailer
they let you know that she was able to
find the clues to learn about the
existence of the men in black so she's
already really good at doing detective
work Thor in the movie seems like more
of a warrior type so maybe he's not so
great at doing detective work when you
see her in the London branch she walks
past the little alien cockroach
characters the you I saw making coffee
during the Will Smith movies so they're
back I'm sure there's a couple other
aliens from the Will Smith movies that
will show up in the background too but
they unveil the car it's Alexis
I'm sure black panther would be proud
I'm assuming that Lexus just wanted to
sponsor the movie and that's why they're
using those cars but it is kind of funny
because they're big in the Marvel movies
now they give you a couple car jokes
about Tessa Thompson learning about all
the James Bond style weapons hidden all
over the place so they start pulling off
pieces and assembling guns this is
actually a shot right out of Thor
Ragnarok when Loki and Thor hold up
their weapons and unison and start
firing
[Music]
so even though there are a lot of Thor
Valkyrie jokes in the movie there's also
a lot of visual references to Thor
Ragnarok as well which I'm happy that
they did because this franchise is all
about those comedic moments so it really
does lend itself to that self
referential style of humor them on the
air bike definitely feels like it could
be out of a Thor movie there's a joke
about the neuralyzer I don't know which
city they're supposed to be in here
there's a quick montage of them
traveling to a bunch of different places
around the world
it's Men in Black International they'll
be traveling everywhere so obviously
they tried to visit as many big
locations for the movie as possible
couple more fight jokes about surprise
arms this is just one of those men and
black tropes where it's like well you
know I look human but really I have like
a thousand different things going on
with my body that you don't know about
then they make a joke about the big red
button trope from the Will Smith movies
and they even hold it for a minute like
they're not gonna do it then it kicks in
turns out they're definitely doing it
then they end on what is probably the
most direct reference to Thor Ragnarok
ever when he picks the tiny hammer up
throws it at the alien and the alien
catches it just like hella
[Music]
so if it wasn't clear there's obviously
a lot of chaos happening in the world of
men and black during the course of this
movie but the real goal is is to find
out who the mole in the organization is
I'm still wondering if it winds up being
Liam Neeson because it just seems like
they're setting us up for that kind of
reversal like oh this badass agent
that's been working under him for this
whole time just did not decode the clues
that his superior was pulling a fast one
on them for some crazy reason so let me
know in the comments who do you actually
think the mole is inside the men in
black organization do you actually think
that it's someone that we saw in this
trailer just because it feels like it's
gonna be a big reversal at the end of
the movie but what will happen is is
there supposed to be a couple more big
trailers before the end of the year so
I'll try to get through everything leave
all your requests in the comments below
click here for a new spider-man far from
home and watch Tom Hall and be
ridiculous and click here for my
spider-man into the spider-verse
post-credit scene video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you